when we first really started getting to
know each other back in the day when a
lot of the daily show guys would go over
to comics yeah oh it's absolutely you
were making the move from improv you're
hilarious improviser and sketch guy and
he started doing the stand-up stuff yeah
we're doing more you know a fantastic
Santa but I knew you right when you
start right and so we probably saw some
pretty rough stuff I remember being a
little bit angry that you were good not
not in the shallow a but I was like what
the folk he's just good at everything I
don't think of you as a typical stand-up
like in the in the no no I hope not
because most of stand-ups hmm I know are
from the land of the broken toys they're
crazy they're all crazy and mad and
pissed and jealous and angry and then
also thinking on stage you go huh I'm
gonna come backstage is like that I got
a hell every you know I mean they're the
worst it's unbelievable when you go out
as an ensemble you go over the yeah
group and you all you you do comedy bits
in you you're making it up as you're
building it together and you're
supporting each other and yes and and
you're trying to do all these things and
and when you come off stage I was like
that was great I loved when you did that
and how there's so much love on the
right right right the best and then we
all go drink beer together and I never
forgot I came offstage like right when I
started and a comedian that I knew and
liked and respected and thought we had a
good relationship walked off and I saw
him and I was all ready for a hey not a
boy and he he literally took a drag off
his smoke knows what happened up there
and then walked off I was like I thought
it what the fu oh my god
yeah but you're you're you're former
Marine which means you're a marine right
you're a brain forever
yeah you're Europe you're a marine man
why didn't you grab that plaid clad
mother bingo I got some bits for you
uncle sam says you're welcome huh oh I
did all night in my mind oh yeah
you know someone cuts me off a try block
yeah pull your car over you know I go
through this unbelievable fantasy a kick
in his ass every day you know and all
the great things I would have said yeah
but in the moment I'm like that's enough
of that mr. haha just turn up the Shania
Twain I can't even hear you that tone
impressed me much